This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
When you hear the phrase “brain-eating amoebas,”
is there a particular image that comes to mind?
Maybe you're conjuring up a malignant blob,
one that creeps and eats and
creeps some more, its size growing with every
chunk it rips out of your brain.
Or maybe you're painting a picture of a
shape-shifting pacman-like organism bent on
terrorizing your body.
Or maybe there’s nothing, just, you know, the
existential dread that happens when you mash
a bunch of seemingly unrelated words together,
like “brain-eating” and “amoeba,” only to realize the
threat is actually pretty real.
Whatever you envision (or do not), would
it be strange to suggest that the notorious
brain-eating amoeba that strikes fear in our
hearts actually looks something like
these little guys?
Like tiny little bits of fluff that have just
stumbled into your path?
Now to be very clear, these are not
brain-eating amoebas.
At least, not as far as we know.
They belong to the same general group of organisms
though called amoeboflagellates.
And since we do not, you know, have
some brain-eating microbes on hand,
we are going to use these
amoeboflagellates as sort of a proxy.
As you might guess from the name,
amoeboflagellates take all the crawling and shape-shifting
blobbiness that we love from amoebas, and
combine it with the flagella that powers flagellates.
It’s actually a little more complicated than that,
and that is why we are focusing
on brain-eating amoebas today.
Because they have actually been very well-studied,
because they impact human life pretty substantially.
In 1961, a 9 year old boy died in South Australia.
Four years later, two eight year old girls
died as well.
They had been healthy, but four days before
their death, they reported feeling tired.
The next day, they all had painful headaches
along with a fever and other symptoms.
Around the same time, a twenty-eight year
old man arrived at the hospital with similar
symptoms, and died shortly after.
These cases were documented by Doctor M. Fowler,
and they were all diagnosed with meningitis,
an inflammation of the membranes that protect
the brain and spinal cord.
Meningitis can be caused by bacterial or viral
infections.
But when doctors studied the bodies of the
patients after their death, they did not
find any bacteria or viruses.
They found amoeba.
This was a surprise.
There are other amoebas that dig their way
into human tissues, like Entamoeba histolytica,
the parasite behind diseases like amebiasis
and amebic colitis.
But while Entamoeba histolytica can lead to
meningitis, it is an intestinal parasite.
The organism that killed these patients was
something entirely different:
a free-living organism, not a parasite,
that just happened to find itself in a
prime position in a human nasal cavity to kill.
The amoeba would later be named Naegleria
fowleri for the doctor who first described it.
And it is very important to understand that
Naegleria fowleri does not rely on our brains
to survive.
Members of the Naegleria genus are found around
the world in both soil and water.
They swim around in lakes and non-chlorinated
pools and hot springs.
They can even be found in the nasal passages
of humans who are entirely healthy.
Ecologically, these amoeba likely play an
important role in making sure bacteria populations
don’t go out of control by eating them.
And some, like Naegleria fowleri, love hot
water, which is why they tend to proliferate
in the summer.
Naegleria also change up their form depending
on the conditions around them.
Normally, they exist in their amoeboid form
called a trophozoite.
But when food is scarce or conditions become
unfriendly, they might transition towards
their flagellated state.
And if things get very, very bad, then Naegleria
pull one of the most popular moves in the
microcosmos:
they ball up into a protective cyst, putting
themselves on pause until things improve and
they feel ready to emerge.
Imagine Naegleria spending their days swimming
around, looking for bacteria, and curling up into cysts
when they feel the need for protection…
it’s all a bit quaint for a killer amoeba.
But perhaps that is Naegleria fowleri’s
greatest transformation, the one it embarks
on when it goes from water to a human body.
That shift starts when it inadvertently finds
itself inhaled into a nasal cavity, usually
by someone who has been playing around or
swimming in infected water.
The nose might not be where the amoeba is intended
to be, but assigning intention in the microcosmos
is a pointless endeavor.
The amoeba has found itself in a new habitat,
and so it must adapt.
It begins by sticking itself to the mucus-y
surfaces around it.
The body does not welcome Naegleria fowleri.
Within six hours, the immune system will attempt
to mount one of its first lines of defense,
using a type of white blood cells called neutrophils
to try and control the amoeba.
And over the next few days, the amoeba will
continue its path, undeterred by our body’s
defenses as it reaches the olfactory bulb.
And along its path, Naegleria fowleri will
release enzymes that break down the olfactory
epithelium it passes by, causing destruction
that is felt by the human whose body has become
an unwitting home to the amoeba.
Now we keep calling this a case of brain-eating
amoeba, but the disease itself is actually called
primary amoebic meningoencephalitis.
And as we described in the first reported
cases, the symptoms are painful.
Headaches, vomiting, fatigue, even a coma.
Patients usually die within a week of
these symptoms.
Now the good news is that these
infections are not common.
Between 1962 and 2018, there were 45 cases
in the US, the country that has
reported the most cases.
Of course this only accounts for infections
that were reported, so there may be more.
The bad news is that survival is exceedingly
rare, only around 5% thanks to a drug called
amphotericin.
But if a treatment exists, then
why is survival so rare?
Remember that amoebas are not the only organisms
that cause meningitis, so narrowing down on
Naegleria fowleri as the culprit can be difficult.
And given the rapid destruction of the amoeba,
a delayed diagnosis can mean death.
So what do we do with that?
What do we do with the knowledge that out
there in a lake somewhere is an amoeboflagellate
capable, with the release of a few proteins
and a trip down our nose, of killing us?
I guess we do what we always do.
We watch and learn and try to know more about
a vast world hiding around us.
A world constantly undergoing tiny little
transitions between friend and foe.
Or perhaps, more accurately, a world where
friend and foe is a dichotomy too harsh to
grasp int the myriad relationships in between.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace offers a robust platform
that empowers small businesses to create their
own websites.
Whether you're just starting out or looking
to expand your existing venture, Squarespace
provides all the essential features you need
to succeed.
Maybe you're a talented yoga instructor and
want to establish a captivating online presence
for your studio.
Squarespace provides you with the tools to
design a beautiful and professional website
that reflects your studio's tranquil ambiance
and captures the essence of your teaching style.
Utilizing Squarespace's third-party extensions,
you can effortlessly manage class schedules,
streamline bookings, and offer online yoga
sessions to students around the globe.
And if you're interested in sharing your yoga
knowledge and inspiration with a broader audience,
Squarespace makes it easy to integrate a blog
seamlessly into your website.
You can enlighten your readers with insightful
articles, yoga techniques, and mindfulness
practices, fostering a deeper connection with
your community.
You can even engage with your students through
threaded comments and replies as you encourage
discussions, offer guidance, and celebrate
their progress as they embark on their yoga journey.
You can sign up today for a free trial at
Squarespace.com.
And when you're ready to launch, visit
squarespace.com/microcosmos
to enjoy a 10% discount on your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Thank you so much to all the people whose
names are on the screen right now.
They are some of our Patreon patrons, the
people who make it possible to make this show.
It always makes me feel so good to see these
names.
People who just want to make it possible for
us to continue on this journey, which has
been a really wonderful part of my life.
So thank you so much to all those folks.
If you want to become one of them, you can
go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss.
You can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.